alors le point principal monsieur le
président puisque c'est votre question
c'est comment on arrive à 30 mille ou
cent quarante mille personnes
supplémentaires des 75000 personnes du
stade de france je comprends bien que ce
chiffre est important on n'a jamais dit
si vous me le permettez avec la ministre
des sports que c'était 35 mille faux
billets nous avons toujours dit que
c'était 30000 à 40000 personnes soit non
porteurs de billets soit ayant des faux
billets qui sera ajouté aux 75 une
personne qui eux avaient un vrai billet
alors nous avons au moins de
possibilités de source pour ceux qui ne
croient pas à la préfecture de police la
première peut-être c'est celle de la
fédération française de football qui
avait même communiqué officiellement
vous avez dû voir cela il 75000 et non
pas 80 mille billets édités par la
fédération c'est à dire par
l'organisateur l'uefa fff cent soixante
quinze mille personnes qui auraient dû
se rendre au stade de france
malheureusement nous avons constaté cent
dix mille personnes dans le stade de
france et autour du stade de france
ayant emprunté les transports ça se
décompose comme suit 79 1200 personnes
c'est à dire le plus déjà de nombreux
cas des billets qui ont pris les
transports en commun on a lignes de rer
vous le verrez par lignes de rer les
détails des personnes qui ont été
comptés en en remercie la ratp la sncf
21000 bus de très facile à savoir
puisque l'intégralité des supporters
espagnols organisé par leurs clubs sont
arrivés par des bus c'est le cas
seulement de 1/3 des supporters anglais
c'est aussi un de nos problèmes et puis
évidemment tous ceux qui sont arrivés en
véhicules particuliers 6000 taxi et
chauffeur privé après avoir contacté la
fédération a contacté des sociétés de
taxis et les sociétés privées de
chauffeurs privés qui ont évidemment la
géo localisation de leurs courses et
4100 personnes avec un véhicule
particulier les parkings en font foi
ce qui veut dire vous avez le tableau
récapitulatif
que selon les chiffres donnés non pas
par nous mais par la ratp ou la sncf
attendait pour venir allez-y nous avons
exactement les mêmes chiffres à quelques
centaines ou aller moins de 5000 près
c'est tout à fait possible rappelle que
je regrette personnellement que nous
n'ayons pas pu utiliser des drones pour
pouvoir mettre dans la gestion de la
foule plus de l'image sur nos sujets
mais nous aurons sans doute l'occasion
d'en reparler dans d'autres
circonstances la ligne 13 la ratp
faisait naître 27000 personnes qui sont
venues au stade de france le r vrd nord
37000 on voit bien la sur représentation
du rer d qui d'habitude n'est pas celui
qui accueillent de plus de personnes
puisque celui là que le plus de
personnes c'est le rer b qui la relève
de la sncf je veux dire ici à ceux qui
pensent qu'il ya un problème de chiffres
entre nous que les rer b gare du nord
direct stade de france est gérée par la
sncf et que les chiffres ratp rer b qui
fait des stations c'est j'ose dire
normal et l'a gérée par la ratp ce qui
fait la différence des 6500 que l'on
voit parfois entre les deux comptages et
les 10500 donc gérée par la ratp henry r
b ce qui nous fait donc un sou total
déjà de 80000 personnes qui se rendent
pas être transport public au stade de
france alors que le stade là que 75
mille billets nous y rajoute ont bien
évidemment les taxis des taxis g7 les
vtc de toutes sortes
les gens qui sont arrivés en car les
gens qui sont arrivés en bus des gens
qui sont arrivés en provenance de leurs
propres véhicules dans les parkings et
donc nous attendons tous un chiffrage
qui entre-temps 9000 et 117 mille
personnes c'est-à-dire plus beaucoup
plus de 30000 personnes 34800 sur la
fourchette basse quarante deux mille
huit cents soit fourchette haute ces
personnes soient sont rentrés dans le
stade de façon numéraire à quelques
centaines près sans doute sous loire
sont restées aux abords immédiats du
stade de france soit sont allé un peu
plus loin que les abords immédiats liste
des francs sous l'effet de l'ordre
public mais aussi sous l'effet parfois
des prêts filtrage puisque le pré
filtrage n'a pas fonctionné que dans les
portes sud de liverpool pour les raisons
que j'ai évoquées et partout ailleurs
les gens n'ont pas pu accéder au parvis
du stade de france en ce qu'ils avaient
soit des faux billets soient pas de
billet du tout et puis un deuxième
phénomène qui sont tout à fait louer une
partie des supporteurs c'est que pour
tous ceux qui sont allés au stade de
france la 4g fonctionne mal et quand on
ne rentre pas dans un stade et qu'on
veut regarder un match eh bien on essaie
de trouver quand on est supporters par
ailleurs la captation de son téléphone
et donc ça a sans doute encouragé on le
reverra des gens à partir très
rapidement aussi quand ils n'ont pas pu
rentrer dans le stade alors comment on
peut dire que parce que beaucoup jeudi
les critiques et 10 b l'accord très bien
imaginons qu'il transmet une personne de
plus mais ils sont passés où ses trente
cinq mille personnes
et bien la sncf a elle-même documenté on
vous a également fourni la note qu'elle
nous a fourni qu'à 22h52 c'est à dire au
lendemain de la première mi temps de
très nombreux supporters ont commencé à
reprendre les métros et en l'occurrence
ici le rer d et donc comment ça s'est
passé il ya eu un décalage une demi
heure du coup d'envoi on est passé dès
21h à 21h30 21h30 22h15 première mi
temps 22h15 22h30 mi temps
22h30 23h 15 sein du match et au moment
où la ratp sncf pour répondre à une de
vos questions de l'anticipation attend
la fin du match parce qu'on avait
évidemment décalé avec eux les lignes de
rer après le décalage du du coup de
sifflet final ce qui objectivement est
une grande prouesse de la part de la
ratp sncf de rappeler leurs conducteurs
et leurs tramelot rame de métro dans des
contexte d'hyper urgence eh bien ils ont
même dû anticiper cela puisque dès 22h45
en 252 nous dit la sncf mais les images
de vidéo protection que je ne peux pas
vous fournir pour des raisons de
protection des libertés mais qu' ils
sont à votre disposition je suis sûre
s'ils voulaient demander à qui de droit
démontre que les quais du rer d
notamment de la plaine stade de france
ont plein plein de beaucoup de maillots
rouges et malheureusement la sncf doit
refaire venir très rapidement des trains
et des 22 ans 52 les trains repartent à
paris dans des conditions évidemment qui
n'ont rien à voir avec un match en mal
tout le monde attend en général afin
d'un match lorsque ce match n'est pas
infinie alors je me suis permis ça
répondre à votre question sur notamment
la note de l'adn et nash faire un
comparatif avec la finale de coupe de
france que nous avions organisée si
j'ose dire quelques jours auparavant ce
match de coupe de france était a priori
d'après la dlna ch plus dangereux que le
match de championnat se dit et chacun
sait que certains clubs de supporters
des deux clubs de football qui se sont
opposés je n'aurais pas faire d' insulte
ici particulière aux sénateurs élus de
ces départements poser des problèmes de
supportérisme comme on dit très
important et c'était déjà un match de
football comme d'avions particulièrement
me
autour de l'ordre public et où se
dérouler très peu d'incidents il ya eu
plus de spectateurs plus de billets
vendus pour la finale de coupe de france
que pour la championne aux tic
[Musique]